We looked a couple common coverage metrics that come up in practice.
So, we've looked at statement coverage, which is close relative to line coverage.
We looked at branch coverage, also called decision coverage,
and for most of you out there, these are the coverage metrics that are going to matter for everyday life.
Now, as I said before, there are many other coverage metrics,
and we're going to just look at a few of them.
The reason these are interesting is not because we're going to go out and obsessively
get 100% coverage on our code on all these metrics.
But rather because they form part of the answer to the question
how shall we come up with good test inputs in order to effectively find bugs in our software?
Loop coverage is very easy.
It simply specifies that we execute each loop 0 times, once, and more than once.
The insight here is that loop boundary conditions are an extremely frequent source
of bugs in real codes.
For example, if we had this loop in our Python code,
so for a line in open file--that is to say we want to read every line from the file
and then process it--to get full loop coverage we would need to test this code
using a file that contains no lines, using a file that contains just one line,
and using a file that contains multiple lines.
Now, let's look at a fairly heavy-weight coverage metric called modified condition decision coverage or MC/DC.
If that seems like kind of a big mouthful, there's a reason for that,
which is that MC/DC coverage is required for certain kinds of avionics software.
That is, if you're going to write safety critical software, where if the software fails,
airplanes can fall out of the sky, then one of the things you'll need to do to show
that you're software is correct is get a high-degree of MD/DC coverage.
It's designed to be pretty rigorous but still without blowing up into an exponential number of tests.
MC/DC coverage basically starts off with a branch coverage,
so I'm going to simplify here a little bit, but MC/DC coverage basically starts off with branch coverage.
It additionally states that every condition involved in a decision takes on every possible outcome.
Conditions are simply boolean-valued variables found in tests,
and decisions are just the kind of tests that we see in an if statement or a while loop,
or something like that.
Finally, every condition used in a decision independently affects its outcome.
So, that's kind of a mouthful.
This is going to be hard to grasp unless we go through an example, so let's do that.